I was born in 1925.
I grew up not long after
the end of the First World War,
and then I lived through the next war.
My grandfather was killed
at the beginning of World War I.
He led a charge
and didn't survive it.
At home we had a painting
of my grandfather
and for years I ate all my meals
in front of that painting,
which was very frightening
for a six-year-old child.
My father was in the army,
and on 28 May 1940
he was captured by the Germans.
He was a prisoner of war in Germany
for five years.
I missed him a lot...
I was at an age when boys
really need their father.
We had gone to stay with friends.
Here are my mother, my sisters and I
sitting in a trench at their place.
In 1944, I was able to join
the Belgian army
because the Piron Brigade was recruiting.
My friends and I did our training
with the British army
and I became a radio operator.
We went to the front in Holland.
We stayed there until the war ended
on 8 May 1945.
There's no more war now.
We've had 75 years of peace and fortunately
we now have the European Union.
Thanks to that,
people have got used...
to talking
instead of fighting.
Europe unites us.
Europe has a civilising effect.
I've met German people
in my professional life.
I've never had a problem with that.
Our children, our grandchildren
and our great-grandchildren
have never experienced war.
In historical terms,
that's exceptional.
They have no idea how lucky they are.
We've come to Hotton,
to the British and Commonwealth cemetery.
It's in the Ardennes, in Belgium.
That's why I wanted to bring
my grandson here,
for him to know how,
75 years ago, boys his age
fought here in Belgium
and in the surrounding area
so that we might be here today.
People tend to forget.
There's talk of borders again.
We're seeing a return to futile things
and aggressiveness.
I've always marvelled at the fact that,
from such faraway countries,
boys aged 19 or 20 came here
and died here...
I find it incredible.